foreign
[Music]
come in here
oh are you playing game
what the [ __ ] wait
[Music]
wow
[Music]
Dave hi
what's going on here come in here and
have a seat
I did this all myself
hi same princess
do you love it yes I do
what do you think this is foreign
okay give me your hand this no just give
me hand
so you know I love you right I'm
probably gonna cry
I know you love me you know how much I
love you I love you too babe uh-huh like
more than you probably even know I know
you love me okay
and we've been through a lot in two
years we've been through a lot
are you telling me this I know so I'm
gonna ask you a question
will you marry me
babe
regardless of anything that happens I
want you to know that I'm always going
to be here I'm always I'm not going
anywhere
if marry you is what to make you happy
in this life
I'm ready to marry you telling you
I never expected this
and I'll repeat and say yes yes yes yes
[Music]
oh
oh it doesn't fit
okay because guess what you know how I
do things because I wasn't sure
this one better
[Music]
when Kimberly goes down on her knee it's
not my culture but like it's beautiful
and she's trying to show me how much you
love me and how she's ready to build me
regardless of anything that's going to
happen
I have to accept it it's something
touching actually look at how she taking
much time decorating the whole house it
looks so romantic and I feel
loved
[Music]